brothers and sisters you're about to
witness never seen before debate footage
I have thought long and hard before
releasing this by areas this debate is
against none other than you that's right
I want to preach you how this is one of
the greatest things you can start
supporting this number one well less
than two pounds fifty a week that's less
than a cup of coffee you can be sitting
comfortably in your own and earning the
reward the people accepting Islam across
the world think about it five thousand
people accepted Islam with I era last
year if you have been part of that you
would be getting the reward of every
single deed these new Muslims would be
doing for the rest of their lives let
that sink in not just that but we train
new Muslims and teach them how to do
although and to pray the prophets are
Allah Allah who are Salim said if one
person accepts Islam through you it is
better than the world and everything in
it this is one of the most beloved deeds
to Allah because the Prophet sallallaahu
SLM said the most beloved deed to Allah
is the most regular and constant even
though it were little
this debate is finished debate is
finished and the only person who stands
in your way is you
so what are you waiting for click the
button and donate now
[Music]